welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is David Cameron a professor of
political science at Yale and the
director of the program in European
Union studies at the Macmillan Center he
has been on the show a number of times
to talk about the ongoing eurozone debt
crisis because of the European Central
Bank's announcement last summer that it
will do whatever it takes to ensure the
survival of the euro there has been a
sense that the worst of the crisis is
over and that the euro would survive but
that was before the Italian election
today professor Cameron will discuss
what happened in the Italian election
and how that may affect the survival of
the euro zone
welcome professor Cameron it's good to
be back so let's talk about the Italian
election winners losers well the
election created a number of losers one
big winner and it has left Italy in a
situation of deadlock or stalemate
appearing to be uncover noble and the
background to this is that if you looked
at the polls two weeks before the
election the last polls that were
allowed it looked like the center-left
party the Democrats along with Mario
Monti the Prime Minister he's an
economist and since November 2011 he's
headed a technocratic non-political
government it's also a former student of
okay received his PhD here the
expectation was that the there would be
a coalition between Monte's new
coalition and the center-left coalition
the election was held the center-left
did quite badly in the election they
lost about three and a half million
voters compared with where they were in
2008 Monti did relatively badly
the Berlusconi coalition the
centre-right coalition did better than
everyone thought especially since he's
been in and out of office since 1994
that's so much scandal surrounds us but
the net effect is the margin between the
center left and the center right is very
small but now here's where it gets sort
of complicated and interesting in 2005
Italy changed its election laws so that
allows the largest coalition to get 54%
of the seats in the lower house of the
parliament the Chamber of Deputies so
the center-left coalition received 29
point 5 percent of the vote but because
they edged the Berlusconi coalition by
less than a half a point
they got 340 seats in the Chamber of
Deputies which looks like a safe
majority to govern but there is another
problem which is that Italy has a
bicameral legislature with a Senate and
the Senate allocates the seats in a
different way in the vote they give the
coalition that wins each of the 20
regions 55 percent of the seats the way
it all worked out is that there is no
majority in the Senate the left didn't
get a majority in the Senate the
Berlusconi coalition didn't get a
majority in the Senate and Monti did so
badly in the campaign got about 10
percent of the vote that his coalition
his little coalition doesn't have enough
seats to give either the center-left or
the center-right majority so there's a
stalemate and it's not clear how our
government will be formed the reason for
this and the most interesting new
development in this election is the rise
of a new party called the 5 star
movement led by a former comedian and
current day blogger named bepi Grillo
who received over 25% of the vote that
party was formed in 2009
it's a populist party anti-establishment
anti-austerity skeptical about the euro
it wants to reduce the size of the
parliament and reduce the pay of the
parliamentarians by 50% it's opposed to
the privatization of water and wants
water to remain public it's for free
access to the Internet it ran its
campaign entirely through the internet
and through blogs and rallies large
rallies throughout Italy so does that
mean that with the internet being a
large part of it is it primarily younger
people it's younger people disaffected
people they chose their candidates for
Parliament by an online primary which is
a first
most of the parliamentarians who are
elected by the five star movement will
be people who don't have any political
experience before and they bridge all
kinds of issues from the left to the
right and and share a few positions in
common but the real problem is that the
leader who won't be in Parliament is
opposed to any coalition either with the
left or the right so he has enough
representatives in the Senate about 54
senators were elected by the five star
movement to form a coalition either with
the left or the right but he as opposed
to doing that so it's not clear what
will happen right now with the
government well that is very curious
with the rules that have been changed I
mean that seems to have serious
implications for Italian government
moving forward I think perhaps will they
be looking at
again another change so in the event
this happens again there are there's
some protocol in place well that's one
of the big issues that is on the agenda
and the five star movement and other
coalition's as well want to change the
electoral law and and I think want to
reform it in a way that would avoid this
kind of stalemate I have to say given
the recent history of Italian government
I'm not surprised about the rise of the
five star movement well it stands for
well that's right they represent a
number of issues that are current that
will be that attract people who are fed
up with the established parties fed up
with Berlusconi
who has been in and out of government
for twenty years they are especially fed
up with the austerity that Italy has
been going through that has been
administered by Mario Monti and his
technocratic government and do you think
that's why Monti didn't fare better I
think that's a lot of it when I say
austerity last year the economy
contracted by over two percent so went
into rather steep contraction meaning
that the unemployment rate rose so it's
now over 11 percent in order to it went
into that contraction in part because
Monti raised taxes and reduced spending
in order to reduce the deficit one of
the things he did was he created and
imposed two introduced a new residential
property tax that aggravated any number
of Italians and in fact Berlusconi
during the campaign offered to reimburse
all of the Italians their property tax
from last year to the tune of about four
billion out of his own fortune which
probably this was a you might say a new
low in terms of buying boats in an
election but the austerity has been a
real issue in
Italy and it's the same kind of
austerity we've seen in Spain Greece and
Portugal and Ireland elsewhere in in
Europe and it's quite clear I think that
the five star movement and the
center-left
both advocate and easing of austerity
and eventually they will find their way
I think to some kind of coalition at
least for the short term right now we
are in a situation where Italy if you
read the headlines and the Italian
papers you would see words such as
uncover noble and stalemate now this
kind of thing is nothing new to us we've
seen it in the House of Representatives
and the Senate but it is a problem
clearly it was worked out in this
country and I'm I'm wondering what how
do you think it's going to be worked out
well I think what will happen for the
time being Monti is in power as still in
power office as a caretaker government
on March 15th
the new Parliament will convene and at
that point the President of the Republic
Giorgio Napolitano will lead the
discussions among the parties to form a
government Pier Luigi Bersani who is the
leader of the Democrats of the
center-left party has already suggested
a minority government in which the
democrat in which the five star movement
might join the democrats on an
issue-by-issue basis that the Grillo has
said he's not interested in a formal
alliance with either big party but we're
likely to see a coalition it seems to me
an ad hoc minority government with
parliamentary support from the five star
movement on an issue-by-issue basis for
a short period of time dealing with
issues such as
austerity easing that a bit changing the
electoral system some of those
high-profile issues where the two
parties converge but for the longer term
it seems unlikely and the five star
movement is advocating eventually a new
governor a new election in a year or so
you know I'm curious what the Italian
people think about this five star
movement because it seems to me they
don't really have much experience
governing I mean is that an issue do you
think well it's it's an interesting
movement because it's characterized I
think in the rest of the European press
as sort of an Grillo personally is
characterized as a buffoon in fact there
was a bit of a problem in Germany
yesterday the president had to cancel a
lunch with the head of the Social
Democratic Party their candidate in the
next German election does September
because that individual said that Italy
has two clowns running and one being
Berlusconi and the other one being Pepe
Grillo the president felt that was going
too far and a diplomatic insult and
canceled canceled the lunch I mean the
serious that the real problem is that
you have a party now the leading party
in Italy got 29 percent of the vote and
54 percent of the seats so the majority
doesn't in any way reflect the
Preferences of the population the
Democrats on the center-left have a very
wooden old figure leading it a man who's
been around for a long time former
communist former minister of industry
not very charismatic at all they had a
primary and defeated young
man the mayor of Florence who is much
more charismatic Berlusconi on the other
side is someone who's a caricature of
everything that many people think is
wrong with Italy in terms of conflicts
of interest corruption so forth and so
compared with all of that the you have
this new leader who's come on the scene
and says exactly what a lot of people
are thinking and he's gathered this
agglomeration of voters and supporters
who have many different issues from
ecologist to people concerned about the
Internet to people concerned about the
direct democracy to people who want to
get out of the eurozone people who are
concerned about unemployment a whole
range of issues let me ask you this how
involved are the Italians in the
election what is how many come out to
vote percentage-wise well in this
election about 75 percent voted now that
looks really good from our point of view
that looks great but from the Italian
point of view that's the lowest turnout
they've had since 1946 so this was
really they're very they're very
passionate about their election they are
but a lot of people didn't come out this
time in part because the weather was
lousy there was snow in the north and
and bad weather in the south so there
was some slight reduction in turnout
because of that but there were a lot of
people who are angry frustrated they
don't trust the government they don't
trust the established parties and I
think this movement was playing on all
of that frustration and anger and that's
really what brought people to this new
voice in the political system now let me
ask you this with all of the swirling
problems with the euro how is this
situation
is it going to create more anxiety in
terms of the debt crisis in Europe well
it creates a great deal of anxiety
because as you said at the outset after
last summer when Mario Draghi said the
European Central Bank will do whatever
it takes to keep the eurozone going
there's been a collective sigh of relief
and the eurozone seems to have
stabilized you know it's not the crisis
isn't over
but right now Europe is dealing with
Cyprus which is really a small issue
compared with Greece and Spain and the
issues it was facing a year ago but this
creates a huge problem potentially the
the prospect of instability in your--in
in Italy prospect of easing of austerity
which raises the prospect that perhaps
bond prices of the Europe of the Italian
debt will drop yields will increase and
perhaps we'll get to a situation where
Italy might need support down the road
now the real problem is that Italy's
debt is public debt is two trillion
euros and that's not billion that's
trillion two trillion euros it's more
public debt than Greece Portugal Ireland
and Spain put together and Italy is to
use the old cliche it's too big to fail
and it's also too big to bail and the
problem is that what Draghi said last
summer is predicated on a government
agreeing to conditions for fiscal reform
structural reform austerity policy a
whole range of reforms to improve their
financial and fiscal situation if that
happens the European Central Bank will
buy their bonds but the question is what
happens if you have a government that
doesn't want to negotiate the
conditions and accept the conditions
well then the ECB won't come in and buy
the bonds now we haven't had that kind
of situation yet but the prospect of a
government that would be easing on
austerity meaning the markets might get
a little more concerned about whether
Italy can pay back its debt of two
trillion euros over the over the near
term and longer term raises a prospect
of anxiety and a renewal of this of this
crisis that has now gone on for three
years
so the first reactions to the election
the election took place on this previous
Sunday and Monday the first reactions on
Tuesday were a sharp drop in in stock
markets and increase in yields and bond
yields in Europe it settled down a bit
now and and I think more observers see
the prospect of some kind of patchwork
government for at least the short term
but there is a lot of anxiety now that
this is now reopening a crisis that most
people had thought was settled so do you
think it will get worked out I think it
will I mean there are a variety of
options one option would be in Italy
they could have a grand coalition of the
center left and the center right that's
sort of a very German kind of solution
they've done that in the past in Germany
but these two parties putting together
the former the Democrats former
communists with Berlusconi's party is
something that almost no one thinks can
happen except except perhaps Berlusconi
some observers have talked about a new
election right away but all of the
parties when they think about a new
election immediately calculate will we
do better or worse and there's a real
prospect for the established parties
they might do worse in the new election
and so they don't really want to go in
that direction either so then that
leaves
you some kind of patchwork of a minority
government with parliamentary support
from 5-star and actually there is some
precedent for that in of all places
Sicily in Sicily the first breakthrough
for the five star movement occurred last
October in the regional election in
Sicily where they got 15% and since then
there's been a center-left government
operating with a small centrist party
and then with the big 5 star movement in
Sicily and it's working pretty well and
so there is some possibility moving in
that direction
perhaps with part of the Monti coalition
added in as well although probably not
Monti himself he's seen as too much of a
dour transmitter of austerity to the
Italian people on behalf of Germany and
Berlin which is the general that's the
kind of language that we heard in the
campaign from the Berlusconi camp and
others that that this austerity was
imposed by Germany by Berlin by the ECB
by the Europeans but I do think that
that's probably where we'll go at least
for a short term but it wouldn't be
surprising if we have another Italian
election at about this time next year
well more to come clearly to see how it
shakes out thank you so much for being
here with us today and sharing your work
for more information about Professor
Cameron and his research please visit
our website at Yale edu slash McMillan
Report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the McMillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you